now that we've uh discussed a lot a lot
about your vtuber activities i'm
wondering though what's the what's that
what's the grand plan for caisson what's
what do you want to do what do you want
to achieve
where where is caisson going in 2020
yeah
2022. you're allowed to tell us 2022
[Music]
it's um
i don't know i just started off just
being
a normal delinquent i want to be a
worldwide delinquent worldwide world's
most famous delinquent people step aside
that's another mr worldwide mr worldwide
delinquent
uh i don't know i i just didn't set a
goal for myself you know just taking it
day by day yeah are you the kind of
person who like makes goals for
themselves in like
daily life or anything or are you just
kind of like uh i'll do whatever i want
kind of i'll do whatever i want kind of
person
that makes sense i feel like that's very
common amongst creative fields yeah yeah
well i mean there are people who are
compulsively planning every little
detail of that creation yeah yeah but i
think you're trying to do that once
well plan how did what happened
you said it like something went horribly
wrong what happened i did that once yeah
it just broke me down
my brain couldn't just
so when you make the like when you were
like making cosplays you just kind of
winging it you're like i'm kind of
eyeballing it you wouldn't measure
anything you're just like i never
measure oh my god okay and if it went
wrong
i feel that's like true talent though
right it's like people who are like i've
never cooked this thing in my life
two seconds look at the recipes like
yeah i can cook people who don't know
how to like play piano uh read the piano
they should learn it from my ear or
something oh yeah yeah people can like
hear from me that's crazy that's crazy
to me so i i can't i can't even play ddr
without like like in general oh i can't
play ddr either how do they people how
people are good at that game practice
it's insane yeah yeah like i it's like i
don't know if someone can explain it to
me but can you explain why some of like
the most famous composers to ever live
were like deaf deaf yeah how does that
work they just they just knew
well i guess that's the biggest mystery
right it's not like like mozart was deaf
but he wrote his first symphony when he
was five years old
and no both mozart and
death yeah
i'm pretty sure mozart was dead i'm
pretty sure beethoven's death yeah um
yeah beethoven i think wrote his first
symphony when he was like five years old
yeah and he's like he just he just knew
man what else what was i doing at
play i wonder
i wanna i wonder if it was just like
probably i mean back then gundam figures
like you know now that's what i call
music one because there's like two songs
around there i'm sure it was easier to
get them get away with making something
yeah i mean come on there's no music we
all know beethoven invented music oh
that was like there was like yeah name a
song before beethoven
cave music exactly like joey was neither
blind or deaf yeah yeah oh really mozar
was blind no no he wasn't and that's
that's helen keller i'm glad we fat
check this
helen keller is
i know there was like piano battles they
used to have back in the day that
sounded so cool yeah it's like a rap
battle of like where mozart like wiped
the floor with another famous uh
computer or something i think actually
something like that yeah she's such a
badass bro it's been a while it's cause
he's got the hair bro you seen his hair
it's insane
i mean everyone had that kind of hair
back that was insane bro that man had a
massive mane he had to do man that man
was making music
[Laughter]
man discovers mozart
in 2022. he's making music
you know that new guy mozart
make some bangers dude
did you go to conventions anime
conventions i never went to the
conventions before would you be
interested yeah would you ever want to
go oh yeah of course yeah okay here's
the thing would you go you wouldn't
leave my house would you go as your v
tuber model or would you would you do
like the full rtx render and uh yeah
attending like a cosplayer
i would love to attend in cosplay with
this socho cosplay
oh yeah that'd be pretty cool
imagine getting a picture with caisson
irl rtx turned on hd 4k under
i'm sure people would freak out yeah
that'd be awesome do you want to go to
like cons in america as well
oh what do you want to go to cons in
america as well or just japan
um i would love to go to america and do
that before our show americans i imagine
are quite different from japanese yeah
it is yeah i'd say so yeah from what
i've heard i have not been to a japanese
convention at like right now but what
japanese conventions are there aside
from comic
comic-con oh sorry comic-con comic-con
i haven't i haven't been to comic-con
but i've just heard not good things i've
from what i've seen it's just a line
that you you join to buy things yeah
it's a it's a dojin convention
buy it then get in another line buy it
get another line credit where credits do
i think america has the best cons i
think they do it good
uk sucks really yeah it sucks you you
okay
uk doesn't have uk don't have cons they
have drinking parties with some anime
figures drinking parts
it's like in like but it's always in
like uh a venue where you'd have like a
school dance
it's never like an actual that it's
small it's not like a concert hall uh
you know it's literally just a place to
go drink people who like anime cause
like
one thing i love about american cons is
that they have events going on they have
events like to me i remember going to my
first british con and seeing what their
events like schedule was and it was
basically nothing you go there to drink
right i know even now huh yeah even now
yeah half of my panels were in a bar
area
so
they got their priorities yeah they
would you'd have the panel and um like
if you were like put like i guess uh
perpendicular to it was it a bar so
while you're doing your panel people are
lining up to get beer and stuff
so it's like you're basically doing a
pulp show basically because they they're
most more
yeah yeah
like i don't even know what the biggest
anime convention in the uk is right now
you count mcm yeah
it doesn't suck in uk
wow
round of applause for that ladies and
gentlemen
i i would shake your hand case on but i
can't unfortunately but i'll do like a
virtual handshake oh god hold up where
did you hear this from who told you the
uk sucks who told you this
who told you this huh um
but i don't hear anything that doesn't
suck
so i i just needed some information
to change my mind
we destroyed the most 5g towers per
person i think that's the uk doesn't
suck change my mind change my mind do
you like pubs
uh
yeah
as a delinquent you should then you'll
love it that's that's that's what we
have going for okay it's nothing but we
have lots of pumps greg's you wouldn't
know what that is but
uh i think you'd like it
there's a certain chain called tesco's
testicles
no not testicles
very
the royal family is there for the queen
the queen
and palace i'm really finding what
finding it hard to have ways fish and
chips do you like fish and chips fish i
i don't eat fish and chips in the uk
i also don't care about the world family
in the uk
who doctor who is from the uk uh welsh
gone actually it's like okay it's
different please differentiate nando's
and well that's south african though
okay um i will say what we're good at in
the uk is taking other ideas
and
or just taking other things periods
don't ask where the british museum got
all their stuff from that's remember one
of landing in the uk you heard of uh
devious licks that was a tick-tock trend
that the uk started back in uh
back in the 17th century or whatever we
are used to foreign foods we have a lot
of it it's really good uh i said i'd say
you can get some pretty good authentic
of everything i guess yeah that's that's
because we don't have like our own food
that's very good so we just have all the
other countries food and let them let
them teach us how to make it kind of
like it's kind of like that in australia
as well though too
northern ireland and uh scotland are
beautiful
wales is beautiful
[Music]
like it still sucks
no we're still having